he's one of my favorite players that I
got the cover and humans that I got to
meet there's really nobody like him and
he's got a new podcast that's coming out
later this month on Friday May 22nd
every Friday a new episode of its
podcast every day greatness will be out
there and the host of that show Ray
Lewis joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show how you doing ray my friend how are
you I'm doing fine so if your podcast is
called everyday greatness I'm the first
guest right correct ray you've been
around me you've been around me you know
how I operate how I host I'm a leader
I'm a leader of analysts right
you know that I'm doing fine everybody
healthy and your family everybody good
hey I'm just gonna go right in I've been
wanting to ask you this question cuz
everybody's been talking about it with
the last dance of Jordan you watching
this documentary right okay and and how
Jordan you know the conversation that
we're having right now about this doc is
Jordan's leadership and his method his
style of demanding from his teammates
and how it really wore on him it seems
but he didn't care
he basically said if you don't agree
with me it's because you haven't won
anything what do you think of when you
hear that right yeah we there are so
many different styles of of leadership
and and take his you know in particular
you know that's that leadership came
from being denied something you know I
mean you go back and you Lou resource
Michael Jordan's history is one thing to
watch it now
like oh my gosh I can't see he was like
that you know it's another thing to read
his story enough to understand that one
kid that was cut from the basketball
team that they said he wasn't good
enough to do it you know and the things
that came along with that and that comes
that deals them in tile
right and and it's exactement ah there's
a lion lion I'm freaking out why is a
lion don't get up and hang out was
evilest a lion
picture of his product every day enjoyed
and had a mentality like a lion like he
went at it you know this is colder Bryan
had had that had that mentality just and
and sometimes you can look at it right
as being you know a dictator and and
really being harsh and some other can
can really be viewed that way rich um I
tell you somebody who changed my
perspective about that was Mike
Singletary when Mike Singletary coached
me and you know there was a time on
climate Jets I never forget it and Mike
Nolan was beeps according to the time he
called a defense that I knew was not
gonna work it wasn't the right defense
to be in a run
you know star offense and I'm I'm losing
my mind on the field just losing my mind
and I came to the feeling and this was
captured on the sidelines of course on
video but singletery grabs him and he
says look at me he says you look at me
and you know I'm heated at this time
rich I'm like losing my mind he's like
looking man I'm like okay so but cause
I'm looking and he's like wait you can't
do this there's no way you can do that
if we give you something but it forever
changed my leadership style
why because I understood that you can't
speak to everybody a certain way so when
you think about how Jordan did it I'm
telling you a lot of that comes from the
things that he didn't have or was taken
away from him before he was Michael
Jordan and that is he didn't have a plan
B you know and and and I'm and I'm
telling you like when you think about my
podcast like every day greatness the
reason why I'm starting this podcast for
that rich is that simple message like
don't how many of us still to the day
will sit down and question Bruce Lee to
ask Bruce Lee what is greatness what is
it what what turn what what made you
turn that on and never turn it off right
a good friend of mine go home and go a
good friend of all of us Kobe Bryant
write what you want to know what that
greatness is why
why what fired you what what got you
ignited and there's the same thing with
with with Jordan it's the same thing
with Michael selves it you can go down
the line of all of these incredible
stories of these things Catholics and
men who've done so many things but we
don't have the essence of it and so when
you watch this last ride with Jordan all
you saw was the essence of I don't have
a plan B there's no there's no other
option for me this is what I'm I'm built
to do this I'm going to do this and
there's no other direction but
straightforward to get this done and
look something some people could call
the horse we would call it crazy but if
you if you get results the way that they
had they got results list I don't never
condone disrespecting a man to a certain
way but there are certain leaders that
will built with one mentality and that
is I don't have a second option you know
I talk to my kids I talk to people
around the world about that all the time
you know social media and these new new
outlets and they've given us Plan B
which when I was growing up I didn't
have a plan B there's no plan B the only
plan I had was a man to sitting it
didn't cross I mean she can't beat me
why cup he can't outwork me what does
that mean
insane many jumpers that Michael Jordan
shot behind that house the same jumpers
that cold the brass shot behind that
house nobody else was down it when
nobody else buying it out and those and
that's the essence of of what a leader
that you can't it's almost like you
can't mold that again well I mean yeah
when it all comes down to it though ray
is that you did at some point realize
and maybe another first ballot
hall-of-famer from your position how to
get in your face to kind of show you the
mirror in that regard so you know the
question is is looking at Jordan and you
know is he a nice guy or is he not a
nice guy was he good team that was he
not a good teammate again I don't know
if you saw one of the documentaries over
this weekend him recounting
how relentless he felt he had to be the
fact that he had no plan B it wore him
he kind of broke down at the end
thinking about how he might be viewed
ray and I'm and that's what I'm saying
Richard does it does he and and that's
the point in the middle of my career
where Mike Singletary gave me a
different outlook on what leadership is
and right after that day right after
that actually me and him talk about it
all the time every time we see each
other
but the next conversation we had from
that point rich hmm instead of him
teaching me football and how to make
this player make that play we started
meeting every Monday after film study me
and him started meeting in our own
linebacker room nothing about football
he brought his Bible open up the Bible
and started teaching me the principles
of what a man should be like and the way
a man should carry himself and the way a
man a man of humility that loves God
speaks to the people and and I'm telling
you like in the middle of my career in
the middle of my crackers of course you
know when you're passing it you just go
right you go when you push butBut but
you step on people and you crush people
and you and you and you taken and
everybody in locker rooms and and and
whatever it may be
everybody don't have your same Drive
they don't have your same opportunity
right you don't have it right so now you
have to you have to find it differently
you have to find a way to push their
buttons and hopefully you don't do it so
where they look at you and say I hated
him you know because that was part of
what you heard from some of his
teammates you know I mean the judge
Buller said they were afraid of him now
I know I know I spoke to a lot of
players who played with you Ray and they
said they were afraid to come back to
the sidelines and look you in the eye if
they blew an assignment or something
like that that I know I've spoken to
people like that yeah but that was a
that was a different point of
accountable
right that was me saying you I'm gonna
hold you accountable mean you went over
this so now I'm gonna hold you
accountable to that so when you come to
the sidelines don't give me no excuse
not not look we're gonna blow coverage
right are you gonna blow cover -
absolutely are you gonna forget some
absolutely that's easy but I'm talking
about but your effort your effort and
that's what that's what my stander was
right my standards i'ma set this bar so
high that when you look at your leader
this is what the the way your leader
leans but I will never I never forget
this I never forget this this is how I
knew everything things for me and what
my role was as a leader ladarius web
we're playing the Pittsburgh Steelers
and it's a third down in 23 right nobody
gives up 30 down to 23 hey one thing you
tell the corner
it's just turn around I just run nothing
behind you right right and the ball gets
behind him and I'm sprinting down field
and first thing his mouth was sorry what
I don't care about this plate I care
about the next one I wanna know what
your mindset is now that we get that
we've given that up I'm not exaggerating
that kid entire career changed after
that play what would the pre Singletary
talked to Ray Lewis have said if he gave
up a third and 23c and and and and
that's what you can't you can't dictate
it right right because it comes from a
place of not only passion but it come a
place of of hurt they come from a place
of pain they come from a place why are
you doing it like you you know like you
just been raised and when you in battle
you know it takes a very calm warrior to
understand how you must lead your troops
so I'm and and and and it became a gift
it became a true gift of mine that I
really started to her
and realized that you know what rate
this has this is much bigger than just
sports this is everyday life no doubt
yeah and when it all came down to it ray
how many players did you text either
before or after a game day Sunday that
weren't on your team around the league
towards the end of your career how many
how many give me a number on my of
people whose numbers you collected and
you wanted to check in with them they're
not on your team but you just wanted to
check in with them as colleagues
brethren brothers however you want to
put it how many what was already you
know it's a lot
give me a lot what is it was about a
hundred yeah was it was it triple digits
easily like it wouldn't that's why I'm
saying that you can't count the numbers
because let me tell you why you can't
count the numbers rates because it still
happens I do it every other day you know
is and and and and that's what I'm
saying about about true leadership right
true leadership on the court or on the
football field it's only to obtain the
goal of winning a championship of game
whatever my leadership change my
leadership changed to and this is why
the numbers still come in the call still
come in mm-hm
because my leadership changed that I
wanted to make men better men because if
you have a better man if you have a
better man you got a better football
players you got a better teammate you
got a better husband you got a better
father you have all of these things if
you make the man better but you must
make him hold himself accountable that's
where those phone calls - I don't care
what was I was playing against at the
time you know I mean people were the
people with the thought I was crazy
the many times on a Saturday night that
I'm going through the Bible readers hair
Johnson you know did it sinking in with
Chad though did it sink in I think I
think I think now you do I know
and and and that's the after that's the
after the game that makes it so relevant
rich then I'm telling you that I really
appreciate it's like me like right now
right the conversations that I have
weekly with Bobby Wagner or just just
having these conversations with these
kids over and over and over you know but
their DNA DNA developments in these
young men and so being life starts to
change because it goes from just
football stuff to how do I become a
better man off the field how do I become
a better businessman how do so now all
of those factors is kind of where our
transition to now and so yeah I do go
back into the game a lot right a man
Barbie go through a lot I'm going at it
um well hopefully things give adenomas
but oh my god to just film sitting down
with him because I think you know one of
its he's probably one of the most one of
the best linebacker says yeah the middle
backer right in Academy game yeah ray I
think he's going to share that room in
Ohio with you and it's all said and done
for him I think I like him I like that
kid I love him as a person he's one of
the most humble kids he's great and I've
ever been around - and he has a great
chance to definitely put on a coat
jacket
great good luck with the pod again you
need that first guest about everyday
greatness I will have you don't you
worry everybody listen to this I will be
calling Rich Eisen to be on my podcast
because I need to know what every day
greatness is from your perspective I
know exactly what it is right I just had
it over the last 15 minutes right back
at your rate let's let's chat again soon
and I'm seriously you need me on your
pot I'm I'm there for you always know
I'm done I'm putting you off fantastic
ran congrats Congrats on the pot look
forward see what you got that's Ray
Lewis right here we could go on and on
with ring hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here